I recently thought I was doing really great, but a pain started in my spine and radiated
all around my ribcage, big red flags. As this is how I began, turns out from an MRI basically,
my whole spine is littered with lesions now, some taking over my entire vertebrae,
now that it's been two weeks and the shock is worn off, I decided to go back to IVC therapy
and ordered 30 milligrams hypermectin to take one a day for 90 days. The ecologist has not
bothered to call me. I don't know what else to do because I am using the right every night and have been
doing so for over a year to have, except for some power outages. I eat really clean and
follow food supplement protocol. There has been one of the biggest and greatest things in my life
lately, and I will always trust God. The best outcomes as is will. If you have any suggestions for me,
I would greatly appreciate them. Yeah, well, I'm very sorry to hear this. I'd remember if
anything does change in anybody's life, like this is the first I've heard about this,
you know, make sure you get a hold of us. Right away, that's what we're here for. I know this
you're getting a hold of us. Maybe you're in shock for two weeks, so this is how you're getting a
hold of us. It's just through a question. I don't know, the Zoom call, but we're here to pray for you,
we're here to seek God's answers in all of this and pray about decisions moving forward, so we're here
for you through the good times and the bad times, so just know that for all of you, that, you know,
I don't want to have to out of the loop when you're needing us. That's what we're here for.
Okay, so some, some comments that I would have on this, 30 milligrams I've erected depending
upon your weight is probably not going to be enough. I've erected. There is a,
anybody can Google it. The chart or looking up, I've erected dosage for cancer and it is based
upon your weight. I'm just typing it in right now. I can see if I can find it. Based upon your weight and
it's just type in that I've erected dosage for cancer, you'll be able to see that, but you do want to
get up to the right dosage for your, for your weight. So I don't think 30 milligrams is enough
I've erected to be at the dose that's recommended for cancer. Number two, the intermediate
vitamin C therapy, I think that's great. That's a great oxidative therapy. If that's what you feel
like, God is leading you to, there's other things like venvenazole that's much less expensive. You
put dollar signs after this in your question. There's venvenazole is much cheaper than I've
erected. You could do both of them together if you wanted to and it's certainly a whole lot cheaper
than the intermediate vitamin C. So give us a call. The other thing you should look at is getting
another cheek swab done. At least have a conversation with me and just call marine and schedule
something as soon as you can. I would like to chat with you about this. So
I definitely were praying for you. So you don't have to know who this is to be prayed for someone
that I know all you guys know that. You need to be praying for each other. One of the greatest things
that could happen when you go through a difficult time is that you
grow in your empathy for others. And I know it's easy when we're going through a difficult time
that we are become very self-focused. But our priorities to be that we become very God-focused.
Like this person said, they're trusting God's will in their life and we become other people-focused.
And we pray for other people. Sometimes that's the greatest thing we can do. We say,
well, that's the least I could do is pray for you. Yes, we're supposed to help out as many things
as we can do if we are gifted to do so. But that's not a small thing to do when we pray for someone.
That's a very big thing to do. So I had to ask that everybody listening to this or who listens to this
is future be prayed for each other. Pray for this person who just found that they have cast
assists. Pray for other people, not only for healing, but for God's will to be dealt with their life
for a greater, deeper, stronger relationship with him. And that's the key. So
this person asked that they get ahold of us. I will look up who this was and I'll have
to bring you to reach out to you as well.